if you've ever wondered how long a  studio has to wait between one of their  stars getting into massive headline  causing problems and starting to promote  that project again apparently it's about  a month and a half yeah Warner Brothers  is starting promotion for the flash up  again in a low-key way they debuted a  quote unquote new logo it's actually the  exact same logo just with black accents  and a different background but uh it's  interesting that they're starting that  movie again now as I said Ezra Miller  has pretty much stayed out of the  headlines for about a month and a half  since they pled not guilty to the uh  numerous charges that they are currently  facing in Vermont now uh while this  apparently has been long enough for  Warner Brothers Discovery to start  promoting the movie again they are going  to be sweating bullets come January when  Miller has their court date I'll be  really curious to see how badly that  goes for public relations